The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES DICARLO: So let
me start by first--
I already alluded to
this, but let's talk
about the problem of vision.
This is just one
computational challenge
that our brains solve, but
it's one that many of us
are very fascinated by.
As you'll hear in the
rest of the course,
there are other problems
that are equally fascinating.
But I'm going to talk
about problems of vision.
I'm going to talk about a
specific problem of vision,
and that's the problem
of object recognition.
So I will try to
operationalize that for you.
And one thing you'll
see when I talk
is that our field,
even though we
can be motivated by words like
vision and object recognition,
we're going to
only make progress
if we start to
operationally define things
and then decide in what domain
models are going to apply.
And I think that's an
important lesson that I hope
will come across in my talk.
So this is the way computer
vision operationally
defines part of the problem of
object recognition and vision.
It's as if you take
a scene like this
and you want to do
things like come up
with an answer space that
looks like this, where you
have noun labels, say a car.
And you have what are called
bounding boxes around the cars,
similarly for people,
or buildings, or trees,
or whatever nouns that
you or DARPA or whoever
wants to actually label.
Right, so this is just one way
of operationalizing vision.
But I think it gets at the crux
of what we're after, which is,
there is what's called
latent content in this image
that all of us instantly
bring to our memories,
that we can say, aha, that's
a car, that's a building.
There are nouns that
pop into our heads.
We also know other latent
information about these things,
like the pose of this car,
the position of the car,
the size of the car.
The key point that I'm
going to tell you today
about this problem is that
that information feels to us
that it's obvious,
but it's quite
latent in the image--
that's implicit
in the pixel representation.
Those of you who have
worked on this problem
will understand this and those
of you who haven't, I hopefully
will give you some flavor for
what that problem feels like.
So I want to back up a bit.
This is more from a cognitive
science perspective,
or a human brain perspective,
to ask, why would we
even bother worrying about this
problem of object recognition?
And maybe this is obvious
that those of you-- and I
don't need to say
this, but I like
to point out that we think
of the representations
of the tokens of what's
out there in the world
as being the substrates
of what you might do,
what's called higher level
cognition, things like memory,
value judgments, decisions
and actions in the world.
Imagine building
a robot and having
it try to act in the
world and it doesn't even
really know what's out there.
So these are the sort of
substrate of these kind
of cognitive processes.
Again, from an
engineering perspective,
these are processes
or behaviors.
This is just a
short list of them
that might depend on
your good abilities
to recognize and discriminate
among different objects.
I think if you look
through this list,
you could imagine things that
would go terribly wrong if you
didn't actually do a
good job at identifying
what's out there in the world.
So that's just to
think about, again,
as an engineer building a robot.
This is a slide
I stuck in that I
want to connect to
this course, the idea
that I know many of you are
from maybe these backgrounds,
or from this background.
And when I think
about the brain,
I have this coin
here to say, really
these are kind of two sides--
we're studying the same coin
from two directions here.
And really the
question that we have
to all be excited about,
I hope many of you
are excited about it is,
how does the brain work?
And you could do
computer science
and not care at all
about this question.
I think it's a little
harder to do these and not
care about this question.
But it's possible, I guess.
So these are all trying
to answer this question.
And this is maybe
pretty obvious,
but when you have
biological brains that
are performing tasks better
than current computer
systems, machines that
humans have built,
then the flow tends to
want to go this way.
You discover phenomena
or constraints over here.
These lead to ideas that can be
built into computer code that
can say, hey, can I build
a better machine based
on what we discover over here?
And many of us who came into
the field excited to do this
and are still excited of
this kind of direction.
But an equally
important direction
is that when you
have systems that
are matched with our
abilities, or that
can compute some of the things
that we think the brain has
to compute, then the
flow goes more this way,
where there's many possible
ways to implement an idea
and these become falsifiable.
That is, that they can be
tested against experimental data
to ask which of these many ways
of implementing a computation
are the ones that are actually
occurring in the brain.
And that's important
if you say you
want to build
brain-machine interfaces,
or fix diseases, or
do something that's
on the level of interacting
with the brain directly.
I hope that you guys
keep this picture in mind
because I think it's sort
of the spirit of the course
that both of these
directions are important.
And it's not as if we work on
this for 20 years and then work
on this for 20 years.
It's really the flow
across them that I think
is the most exciting to us.
So just to connect to that,
a little bit of history
of where was the field on this
problem of visual recognition.
I don't know if many
of you heard this,
but here you are
at summer school,
so there was a Summer
Vision Project--
it was called, at MIT.
I used to think this
story was apocryphal.
In 1966, there was a
project that the final goal
was object identification,
which we'll actually name,
Objects by Matching the
Vocabulary of Known Objects.
So this was essentially
a summer project to say,
we're going to get a couple
undergraduate students together
and we're going to build a
recognition system in 1966.
And this was the
excitement of AI,
we can build anything
that we want.
And of course, those
of you who know this,
this problem turned
out to be much, much
harder than anticipated.
So sometimes problems that
seem easy for us are actually
quite difficult. If
any of you wants this,
I would be happy to share
this document with you.
It's interesting, the space
of objects that they describe
things like recognizing--
of course, I would say like
coffee cups on your desk.
But they also say packs of
cigarettes on your desk.
So this sort of dates
the time of this here.
So it's a little bit like
Mad Men or something.
So now, here we are today.
And I guess I just can't help
but sort of get excited about,
here's this really cool
machine that's just amazing
that does these computations.
The things got-- I can't tell
you all this because of the 100
billion computing elements,
solves problems not solveable
by any previous machine.
And the thing, it looks
crazy, but it only
requires 20 watts of power.
Those of you who
have seen this slide,
I'm not talking
about this thing.
I'm talking about that
thing right there.
So this is a scale
of what we're after.
And we often talk about power,
but this is something engineers
are especially interested in
as they build these systems, is
how does our brains solve these
problems at such a low wattage,
so to speak.
This is, again, the spirit
of many of the things
that I hope that you guys are
excited about in the future
of this field.
Here's another slide
that I pulled out
that I often like to show
is that, from an engineer's
point of view, we
often try to say,
well, we want to build
machines that are as
good or better than our brain.
So machines today, you
guys know this, beat us
at many things,
straight calculation,
they beat us at chess.
When I was a grad student,
they recently won at Jeopardy.
In memory, they've
always beaten us.
Machines are way better
at memory than us
in the simple form of memory.
Seeing, in pattern
matching, go to the grocery
store, hey, what's
that bar code done?
I don't know what that
was, but it just scans in
and somehow it does
pattern matching, right?
So there's forms of
vision that machines
are way better than us.
But some forms of vision that
are more complicated that
require generalization,
like object recognition,
or more broadly,
scene understanding,
we like to think that we
are still the winners at.
And even things that we take
for granted, like walking,
this is quite a
challenging problem.
So engineers really want
to move this over here.
So our goal is to discover
how the brain solves
object recognition.
And the reason I put this
up is, from an engineering
point of view, that just doesn't
mean write a bunch of papers
in a textbook that says,
this part of the brain
does it, but actually help to
implement a system where this
is, at least, matched with
us and I assume someday,
will be better than us.
And this is also
a gateway problem.
That is, even if it's
just this domain,
we think that the
systems we're studying
might generalize to other,
for instance, sensory domains.
Gabriel told me you
were going to do
an auditory, visual comparison
session later in the week.
That's an engineer's
point of view,
how do I just build
better systems?
Let's step back and talk from
a scientist's point of view.
So this is really now to
introduce the talk that I'm
going to give you today.
So when you're a
scientist, what's our job?
We say we want to understand.
We all write that, understand.
What does that mean?
Well, what it really
means if you boil it down,
and I would love to
discuss this if you like,
is that you have some
measurements in some domain.
So you can think of this
as a state space here.
This is like the position
of the planets today.
And this is like the position
of the planets tomorrow.
Or you could say, this is the
DNA sequence inside a cell.
And this is some protein
that's going to get made.
So you're searching for
mappings that are predictive
from one domain to another.
And we can give lots
of examples of what
we call successful
science, where that's true.
This is the core of science
is to predict, given
some measurements or
observations, what's
going to happen either in
the future or some other set
of measurements.
So predictive power is
the core of all science
and the core of understanding.
And I think it would be fun
if you want to debate that,
that you think
there's another way.
But this is what I come to in
thinking about this problem.
And the reason I'm
bringing this up
is because the accuracy
of this predictive mapping
is a measure of the strength
of any scientific field.
And some fields are
further along than others.
And I would say ours is
still not very far along.
Our job is to bring it
from a nonpredictive state
to a very predictive state.
And so that means building
models that can be falsified
and that can predict things.
And you'll hear that
through my talk.
As Gabriel mentioned,
what we try to do
is build models that can predict
either behavior or neural
activity.
And that's what we think is
what progress looks like.
So now let's translate
this to the problem I gave
you, which is the problem
of vision or more generally
object recognition.
You could imagine, there's
a domain of images.
So just to slow down
here, just so everybody's
on the same page,
each dot here might be
all the pixels in this image.
In this dot, all the
pixels in this image.
So there's a set of
possible pixel-images
that you could see.
And we imagine that they
give rise to, in the brain,
some state space.
Think of this as the whole brain
for now, to just fix ideas,
that you could imagine that this
image, one you're looking at,
it gives rise to some
pattern of activity
across your whole brain.
And this image gives rise to a
different pattern of activity
across your whole brain.
And loosely, we call this
the neural representation
of this thing.
But then what we do is
somehow when we ask you
for behavior reports,
there's a mapping
between that neural
state space and what
we measure as the output.
Whether you say it or
write it, you might say,
that's a face, these
are both faces,
if I asked you for
nouns among them.
OK, so this is another
domain of measurement.
So now you can see I'm setting
up the notion of predictivity.
And what we want
to do is, we have
this complex thing over
here of images that somehow
map internally into
neural activity
and then somehow
map to the thing
we call perceptual reports.
And notice I've
already put things
that we call nouns
that we usually
associate with objects, cars,
face, dogs, cats, clocks,
and so forth.
OK, so understanding this
mapping in a predictive sense
is really a summary of what
our part of the field is about.
And again, accurate
predictivity is the core product
of the science that
underlies our ability
to build a system like
this-- many of you
are interested, to fix
a system like this,
or to perhaps even
augment our own systems.
If we want to inject signals
here and have them give rise
to percepts, we have
to know how this works.
A big part of the
field of vision
is spent-- a lot of
the last three decades,
working on the mapping between
images and neural activity.
That's usually called encoding,
predictive encoding mechanisms.
And it's driven by
Hubel and Wiesel's work.
The people saw this as
a great way forward.
It's like, let's go
study the neurons
and try to understand what
in the image is driving them.
That is, what's an
image computable
model in the world that
would go from images
to neural responses?
The other part is that there's
some linkage, we think,
between the neural
activity and these reports.
And notice, this is
actually why most of us
get into neuroscience
because you
notice this arrow is two-way.
This is actually
quite deep here.
From an engineer's
point of view,
you go, well, there's
got to be some mapping
between the neural
activity and the button
presses on my fingers or
my saying the word noun.
There's some causal linkage
between this and the things
that we observe
objectively in a subject.
But this is where philosophers
debate about like, well, you
know in some sense
these are sort
of two sides of the same coin.
We say our own
perception, there's
some aspects of the
internal activity
that are the thing that we
call awareness or perception.
Now I'm not going to
get into all that,
but I just want to point
out that if you're just
building models, you
can't approach that.
It's this sort of strange
thing between neurons
and these reported states that
many of us are fascinated by.
So this is called predictive
decoding mechanisms.
For me, it's all going
to be operationalized
in terms of reports
from humans or animals.
And I'll not do that
philosophical part,
but I thought I'd mention
that for those you like
to think about those things.
So for visual
object perception, I
want to point out that, again,
the history of the field
has been mostly here.
This link has been
neglected or dominated
by weakly predictive
word models.
That doesn't mean they're
not useful starting points,
but they're weakly predictive.
And so a weakly predictive
word model would be--
and for temporal cortex,
a part of the brain
I'm going to tell you about
today, does object recognition.
That model has been
around for a long time.
It is somewhat predictive
because it says,
you take that out and
all object recognition
will get destroyed,
would be a prediction.
Turns out that doesn't
actually happen.
We can discuss that.
But it doesn't tell you how it
does it, how to inject signals,
which tasks are more
or less affected,
so that's what I mean
by weakly predictive.
It's a word model.
Face neurons do
face task, that's
probably true to some extent.
But again, it doesn't
tell us-- it's more tight.
It sort of says, oh, I'll
take out these smaller regions
and there'll be some set of
tasks that involve faces.
I don't know, I won't say
anything about other tasks.
So that's a somewhat more
strongly predictive model,
but still pretty
weakly predictive.
And my personal favorite that
comes in from reviewers a lot
is, attention solves that.
So this is just a
statement that--
just to be on the
lookout for word models
that don't actually have
content in terms of prediction.
I don't know what that means.
I read this as, hand
of God reaches in
and solves the problem.
So there's got to be an
actual predictive model that
can be falsified.
OK, so I don't mean to doubt
the importance of these.
Before people start
giving me a hard time,
there are attentional phenomena,
there are face neurons,
there is an IT,
that's what we study.
I'm just trying to
emphasize for you that we
need to go beyond word
models into actual testable
models that make predictions,
that would stand even
if the person claiming those
models is no longer around,
it would make a prediction.
Let me try to define a domain.
I said we're going to
try to define stuff.
It's hard to define stuff.
It's big, vision,
it's a big area.
Object recognition, I
sort of said it vaguely.
And when I say this, I
include faces as an object,
a socially important when.
You'll hear this
from Winrich I think.
But I want to say, to try
to limit it even further,
that's still a big domain.
And so we tried early on to
reduce the problem even further
to something that is
more, again, naturalistic,
that we think can
give us more traction,
this predictive sense.
So we started by saying, when
you take a scene like this
and you analyze it,
you may not notice it
but your ventral stream, really
your retina has high acuity
in say the central 10 degrees.
There's anatomy that
I'll show you later
that the ventral
stream is especially
interested in processing
the central 10
degrees of information.
So that's about two
hands at arm's length,
for those you see in the room.
So you may have the sense that
you know what's out there,
but you don't really.
You kind of stitch
that together.
And lots of people
have shown this,
the way you stitch this
together is making rapid eye
movements around,
called saccades,
followed by fixations, which
are 200 to 500 milliseconds
in duration.
You don't really see
during this time here.
It's not as if your
brain shuts down,
it's just that the movement
is too fast for your retina
to really keep up with this.
So you make these
rapid eye movements,
you fixate, fixate, fixate.
And what you do is,
that brings this sort
of sampled scene to
the central 10 degrees
that might look
something like this.
So those are 200
millisecond snapshots
across that scan path.
And I'll play it for
you one more time.
Now, you should
notice that there's
one or more objects in
each and every image
that you probably said,
oh, there's a sign.
There's a person.
There's a car.
You might have gotten
two out of each one.
But you were sort of
extracting, at least
intuitively to me, at least
one or more foreground
or central objects when
I show you those images.
And that ability to do what I
just showed you there, we think
is the core of how you
analyze or build up
a scene like this, at least how
the ventral stream contributes.
And therefore, we call
that core recognition,
which I defined as a central
10 degrees of visual field,
100 to 200 millisecond
viewing duration.
And again, it's not all
of object recognition,
but we think it's a
good starting point.
And a way that we probably got
into this is because of a rapid
serial visual presentation
movies from the 70's.
Molly Potter showed
this really nicely.
This is a movie that I've
been showing for 15 years now.
Notice that this is just
a sequence of images
where there is typically one
or more foreground objects.
And you should be quickly
mapping those to memory,
even though I'm not
telling you what to expect.
Like Leaning Tower
of Pisa, right, I'm
not going to tell you that
you're going to see Star Wars
characters-- well, I just did.
But you quickly are
able to map those things
to some noun or even a more
precise subordinate noun.
I know this is Yoda.
So our ability to do that,
we're very, very good at that.
Notice you didn't need
a lot of pre-cueing,
yet you're still
able to do that.
And that is really what
fascinates us about vision
and object recognition
in particular.
Even without featural
attention or pre-cueing,
you're able to do a remarkable
amount of processing.
And I think that's a great
demonstration of that.
And just to quantify
this for you,
because sometimes
people say, well you're
showing it too short.
Your vision system
doesn't do much.
Here's an eight-way
categorization task
I'll show you later under
range of transformation.
These are just
the example images
of eight different
categories of objects.
It doesn't really matter
what I much do here,
you get a very similar curve.
And that is, you get most
of the performance gain
in about the first
100 milliseconds.
This is accuracy, you're
about 85% correct.
This is a challenging task,
as I'll show you earlier.
It looks easy here, but
it's quite challenging.
85% correct, if I let you
look at the image longer,
up to two seconds, you can
bump up to around 90's.
So there is some gain with
longer viewing duration,
but you get--
chance is 50, so you
get this huge ability.
And we're not the
first to show this.
This is just to show you
in our own kind of task
that the data I'm going
to tell you about,
where we show the image for
100 or 200 milliseconds,
this is the typical
primate viewing duration
that I pin this on.
We use this for
reasons of efficiency.
But you see, the performance
is similar across that time.
You get a lot done.
Your visual system does a lot
of work in that first glimpse.
And that's core recognition that
we are trying to study here.
And I know it's not all
of object recognition
or all of vision,
but it's now, we
think, a much more
defined domain
that we can make progress on.
And that's what we've
been working on.
And that's essentially what
I'm going to talk about today.
So think of vision,
object recognition,
within that core recognition.
This is David Marr.
David and Tommy Poggio, I
studied with a long time.
And Tommy wrote the introduction
to David's-- if you guys
haven't read this book, Vision--
has anybody, guys
know this book?
It's really a classic
book in our field.
It's the first
couple chapters that
are the part you
should really read.
That's the best
part of the book.
And one of the things that
you take from this book,
that I think David
and Tommy helped
to lay out a long time
ago, is that there
is this challenge of level.
I think one of the
things I take from this
is, they would try to
define three clean levels.
It turns out not to be
this clean in practice.
But there's one level called
computational theory, what's
the goal, what's appropriate,
what's the logic,
and by what strategy
can it be carried out.
There's another
level which is, OK,
now once you decide that, how
should you represent the data?
How can you implement
an algorithm to do it?
And then there's this
actually, how do you run it,
how do you build it in hardware?
And neuroscientists often
come in, they're like,
I'm going to study
neurons and it's sort of
like jumping into your
iPhone and saying,
I'm going to study transistors.
They often tend to start
at the hardware level.
And I think that's the biggest
lesson you take from this like,
oh wait, there's
something going on here,
these transistors are flying.
And you make some
story about it if you
were recording from
the brain or measuring
transistors in my iPhone.
But I think the important
point to take from this
is it helps to start
thinking about what's
the point of the system.
What might it be doing?
How might you
solve that problem?
And that leads you
then to algorithm.
And then you think
about representations.
So it's sort of a
top down approach,
rather than just
digging into the brain
and hoping that the
answers will emerge.
So I'm going to try to give
you that top down approach
in this problem that
I'm talking about.
I've already given you a
bit of it by introducing you
to the problem.
I'll say a little bit more about
that and step down a little bit
this way.
And so this kind of
thinking, I think,
is important to
making progress in how
the brain computes things.
So here's a related slide
that I made a long time ago
that, again, I
pulled out for you
guys, that I think helps
bridge between what I just
said about the Marr
levels of analysis
and whether you're a
neuroscientist or cognitive
scientist, and are a computer
vision or machine learning
person.
So the first is, what is the
problem we're trying to solve?
So that's Marr
computational level one.
So computational vision--
now operationally,
you'll hear folks
in machine learning,
they might say, well, there's
some benchmarks, that's good.
There's a ImageNet
Challenge or whatever
challenge they want to solve.
Sometimes they'll say,
well the brain solves it.
That's not good because
they didn't really
define the problem.
Neuroscientists
will say, well, it's
something like
perception or behavior
or there's some sort of
behavior that they imagined,
although characterizing
that behavior
is not usually
their primary goal.
But I think there is at least
some progress in that regard.
Now what does a
solution look like?
This is really just to
talk about language.
So useful image representations
for machine learning, like what
we might call features--
but neuroscientists will talk
about explicit neuronal spiking
populations.
You heard this in Haim's talk.
He was using these
words interchangeably.
Again, this may be
obvious to you guys,
but I thought it's
worth going through.
So this is like Marr
level two, representation.
How do we instantiate
these solutions?
So this is still
level two algorithms,
or mechanisms that actually
build useful feature
representations.
Neuroscientists will think about
neuronal wiring and weighting
patterns that are actually
executing those algorithms.
This is what we think is
a bridging language there.
And then there's
this deeper level
that came up in the
questions, which
is, how would you construct
it from the beginning?
Learning rules, initial
conditions, training images,
are words that are used here.
There is a learning machine.
Here, neuroscientists talk
about plasticity, architecture,
and experience.
But again, those are
similar questions just
with different language.
And I'm doing this because I
think the spirit of this course
is to try to build these links
at all these different levels
here.
OK, so hopefully
that kind of helps
orient you to how
we think about it.
Let me just go and say, I
want to talk about number one.
What is a problem we're trying
to solve and why is it hard?
I said, object
recognition is hard
and I showed you that MIT
Challenge and it was difficult.
Maybe it's hard because
there's lots of objects.
Who thinks that's why it's hard?
Who thinks that's
not why it's hard?
You think computers can
list a bunch of objects?
It's easy, right?
This is what I
said about memory,
it's a big long list of stuff.
Computers are good at that.
There's going to be
thousands of objects.
A list of objects is not a
hard thing for a machine to do.
What's hard is that each object
can produce an essentially
infinite number of images.
And so you somehow
have to be able to take
some samples of certain
views or poses of an object,
this is a car under
different poses,
and be able to generalize or
to predict what the car might
look like in another view.
This is what's called
the invariance problem.
and it's due to the fact
that, again, there's
identity preserving
image variation.
This is why the bar code
reader in your supermarket
works fine, because the code
is always laid out very simply.
But when you have to
be able to generalize
across a bunch of conditions,
potentially things
like background clutter, even
more severely occlusion, things
you heard from Gabriel, or you
may even want to generalize
across the class of cars
where the cars have slightly
different geometry but
they're still cars,
these kind of generalizations
are what make the problem hard.
So I'm lumping them
all together in what
we call the invariance problem.
Many of you in the room know
this is the hard problem.
And I think that hopefully
it fixes ideas of, that's
what you should think about.
It's not the number of
objects, but it's the fact
that it has to deal with
that invariance problem.
Haim was talking
about manifolds,
and this is my version of that.
So this is to introduce
you to the problem of,
why that invariance problem--
what it looks like
or feels like.
I'm not going to give you
math on how to solve it.
It's just a geometric
feel for the problem.
So if you imagine
you're a camera--
or your retina,
which is capturing
an image of an object,
let's call this a person,
I think I called him Joe.
So when you see this image of
Joe, and this is the retina,
so now this is a state space of
what's going on in your retina.
So it's a million
retinal ganglion cells.
Think of them as being an
analog value out of each,
so this is a million
dimensional state space.
So when you see
this image of Joe,
he activates every retinal
ganglion cell, some a lot,
some a little, but he's
some point of that million
dimensional space.
OK, everybody with me?
If everybody's heard all this
before and wants me to go on,
everybody wave your
hand and I'll move on.
AUDIENCE: No, it's good.
JAMES DICARLO: Keep going, OK.
So the basic idea is that if
Joe undergoes a transformation,
like a change in
pose, what that does
is, it's only a 1
degree of freedom
I'm turning under the hood
one of those latent variables.
If I had a graphics
engine, I'm changing
the pose of latent variables.
It's only one knob that
I'm turning, so to speak.
And that means there's
one line through here
as Joe projects across
these different images here.
And I'm ignoring
noise and things.
This is just the
deterministic mapping
onto the retinal ganglion cells.
So Joe goes--
[MOVING NOISE]
--and he goes over here.
And if I turn the other
knob, he goes over here.
And so I could imagine,
if I turned those two
knobs of two axis
opposed always possible
and plotted this in the million
dimensional state space,
there'd be this curved
up sheet of points,
which you could think of
Joe's identity manifold
over those two degrees
of view change.
It's only two dimensions,
it's hard to start
showing more than this.
But it's this curved
up sheet of points.
Everybody with me so far?
You don't actually
get to see all those.
You could imagine a machine
actually running them all,
but you don't really
get to see them.
You've got to get
samples of them.
But there's some underlying
manifold structure here.
Now, what's interesting and
what's important to point out
is that this thing,
even though I've drawn
it and it's a little curve,
but it's highly complicated
in this native pixel space.
It's all curved up and
bending all over the place.
And the reason that
matters, and this
is what Haim
introduced you to, is
that if you want to be
able to separate Joe
from another object, say
not Joe, another person say,
then you need a representation.
I showed you retinal
ganglion cells.
This is another
imaginary state space
where you can take simple tools
to extract the information.
And the simple tools
that we like to use
are linear classifiers.
But you can use
other simple tools.
Haim used the exact
same description to you
guys in his talk, that you
have some linear decoder
on the state space that can
say, oh, they can separate
cleanly Joe from not Joe.
So these manifolds
are nicely separated
by a separating hyperplane.
That's what these tools tend to
do is they like to cut planes.
This is one thing
they like to do,
or they want to find
locations or regions,
like compact regions
in this space,
depending on what
kind of tool you use.
But you don't want
the tool having
to do all kinds of complicated
tracing through this space.
That's basically the
original problem itself.
So what you need is, you
have a simple tool box,
which we think of as
downstream neurons.
So a linear classifier,
as an approximation,
it's like a dot product.
It's a weighted sum, which is
what we think, neuroscientists,
of downstream neurons doing.
So it's a weighted sum.
And if we want an
explicit representation
in some neural
state space, then we
need to be able to take
weighted sums of some population
representation to be able to
separate Joe from not Joe,
and Sam from Jill, and
everything from everything else
that we want to separate.
If we had such a space
of neural population,
we'd call that a
good set of features
or an explicit representation
of object shape.
And for any
aficionados here, it's
not just cleanly
linear separation,
it's actually being
able to find this
with a low number of
training examples.
So that turns out
to be important.
But it helps to fix ideas to
think about linear separation,
ideally with a low number
of training examples.
So that's a good representation.
And notice, I'm starting
to mix up terms here.
I am assuming, when
I talk about shape,
that that will map
cleanly to identity,
or what you might call
broadly, category.
That's another topic I won't
talk about, if you just
think about the shape of Joe,
or separating one geometry
from another.
Now, here's a simulation that
my first graduate student, Dave
Cox, who's now at Harvard, did.
This is a number of years old.
This takes these two
face objects, render them
under changes, and view.
And then he actually
simulated the manifolds
in a 14,000 dimensional space.
And then he wanted
to visualize it.
And because we
wanted to try to make
the point that these
manifolds of these two objects
are highly curved
and highly tangled,
this is a three
dimensional view.
Remember, it's sitting on a
14,000 dimensional simulation
space.
You can't view that space.
This is a three
dimensional view of it.
And the point is that it's
like two sheets of paper
being all crumpled up together
and they're not fused.
They look fused here because
it's in three dimensions.
But they're not actually fused.
But they're complicated,
you can't easily
find a separating hyperplane
to separate these two objects.
We call these tangled
object manifolds.
And really, they're tangled
due to image variation.
Remember, if I didn't change
those knobs of view or position
or scale, there would just
be two points in the space
and it would be easy.
That's the easy problem
of listing objects.
But if they have to undergo
all this transformation,
they become these
complicated structures
that need to be untangled
from each other.
So the problem
that's being solved
is, you have this
retina sampling data,
like a camera on the front
end, where things look
complicated with respect
to the latent variables,
in this case shape or
identity, Sam or Joe.
And that they somehow are
transformed, as Haim mentioned,
they're transformed by some
non-linear transformation,
some other neural population
state space, shown here, where
the things look more like this.
The latent variable
structure is more explicit,
that you can easily take things
like separating hyperplanes
to identify things like
shape, which again, roughly
corresponds to identity or
other latent parameters,
like position and scale.
You maybe haven't thrown
away all these other latent
parameters.
And if I have time, I'll
say something about that
so you don't just get identity.
But if you can
untangle this, you
would have a very nice
representation with regard
to those originally
latent parameters.
That's the dream of
what you'd like to do.
It's like reverse
graphics, if you will.
So this is what we call an
untangled explicit object
information.
And we think it lives
somewhere in the brain,
at least to some degree.
And I'll show you the
evidence for that later on.
So what you have then is you
have a poor encoding basis,
the pixel space.
And somewhere in the brain
is a powerful encoding basis,
a good set of features.
And as Haim mentioned,
as I already said,
this must be a
non-linear transformation
because the linear
transformations are just
rotations of that
original space.
So now let's go down
to-- actually this
would be Marr level three.
Let's go to instantiation.
Let's get into
the hardware here.
We're supposed to be
talking about brains.
So I'm going to give you a
tour of the ventral stream.
So we would love to know
how this brain solves it.
This is the human brain.
This is a non-human primate.
This is not shown to scale.
This is blown up
to show you it's
a similar structure,
temporal lobe, frontal lobes,
occipital lobe.
There is a non-human primate.
We like this model for
a number of reasons.
One reason that we
like it is that they
are very visual
creatures, their acuity
is very well matched to ours.
In fact, even their object
recognition abilities
are actually quite
similar to our own.
This may be surprising
to you, but let me just
show you some data for that.
This is actually data from
Rishi Rajalingham, in my lab.
It says, impressed,
but this just came out.
This is the confusion
matrix patterns
of humans trying to
discriminate different objects
under those transformations
that I showed you earlier,
where they're not
just seeing images,
but they have to deal
with these invariances.
And this is rhesus monkey data
trying to do the same thing.
And the task goes, I'll
give you a test image
and then you get choice images.
Was it a car or a dog?
I'll show you an image, what
choice was it, a dog or a tree?
And you're trying to entertain
many objects all at once,
and you get an image under
some unpredictable view
and unpredictable
background, and then
you have to make a choice.
So this is the
confusion difficulty.
And when you look at
this, it's intuitive
that these are sort
of geometry similar.
Camel is confused with dog, and
tank is confused with truck,
and that's true of both
monkeys and humans.
And to some level, this
shouldn't be surprising to you.
The same tasks that are
difficult for humans
are difficult for monkeys
because probably they
share very similar
processing structures.
They don't have to bring
in a bunch of knowledge
about tanks are driven by people
or that, they just have to say,
was there a tank or a truck.
And under those conditions,
they make very similar patterns
of confusion.
And these patterns are
very different from those
that you get when
you run classifiers
on pixels or low level
visual simulations.
But they're very similar
to each other, in fact,
are statistically
indistinguishable,
monkeys and humans, on these
kind of patterns of confusion.
OK, so that's one reason we like
this subject, the monkey model,
is that the behavior is very
well matched to the humans.
The other reason is that we
know from a lot of previous work
that I alluded to, that some
studies have shown that lesions
in these parts of the brain can
lead to deficits in recognition
task.
So again, we think the ventral
stream solves recognition.
So we know a weak word
model of where to look,
we just don't know exactly
what's going on there.
Just to orient
you, these ventral
areas, V1, V2, V4, and infer
temporal cortex, or IT cortex--
IT projects anatomically
to the frontal lobe
to regions involved in
decision and action,
and around the bend to the
medial temporal lobe to regions
involved in formation
of long-term memory.
Because these are
monkeys and not humans,
and Gabriel mentioned this
in his talk, we can go in
and we can record
from their brains,
and we can perturb neural
activity in their brains
directly.
And we can do that
in a systematic way.
This is the advantage of
an animal model as opposed
to a human model.
OK, as neuroscientists
now, we've
taken a problem,
translated it to behavior,
taken that behavior into
a species we can study,
we know roughly where
to look, and now
we want to try to
understand what's going on.
So as engineers, we take these
curled up sheets of cortex
and think of them as I've
already been showing you,
as populations of neurons.
So there's millions of neurons
on each of these sheets.
I'll give you numbers
on a slide coming up.
There's some sort of processing
that may be common here,
I put these T's
in, there might be
some common cortical algorithm
processing forward this way.
There's also
inter-cortical processing.
And there's also some feedback
processing going on in here.
So all that's schematically
illustrated in this slide
that I'll keep
bringing up here when
we talk about these different
levels of the ventral stream.
Now I'm most going to be
talking about IT cortex here
at the end.
Why do we call these
different areas?
One reason is that there's
a complete retina topic
map, a map of the whole
visual space in each
of these different levels.
In retina, there's one.
In LGN-- in the thalamus,
there's another.
In V1, there's another map.
In V2, there's another map.
In V4, there's another map.
In IT, it's less clear
that it's retinotopic,
we're not even sure
that IT is one area.
Maybe we'll have time, I'll
say more about that detail.
So it's not that
retinotopic in IT,
except the most
posterior parts of IT.
But that's why
neuroscientists divide these
into different areas.
So a key concept, though,
for you computationally is,
think of each of these as
a population representation
that's retransforming the data
from that complicated space
to some nicer space.
And it's doing this probably
in a stepwise, gradual manner.
So IT is believed to be
that powerful encoding
basis that I alluded
to earlier, where
you have these nice
flattened object manifolds.
And I'll show you the
evidence for that.
This is recently from a
review I did that gives
more numbers on these things.
And I've sized the
areas according
to their relative cortical
area in the monkey.
Here's V1, V2, V4, IT.
IT is a complex of areas.
And I'm showing you
these latencies.
These are the
average latencies in
these different visual areas.
You can see, it's
about 50 milliseconds
from when an image
hits the retina
until you get activity in V1.
60 in V2, 70-- there's
about a 10 millisecond step
across these different areas.
So it's about 100 millisecond
lag between an image it's here,
and you start to see changes
in activity at this level
up here that I'm referring to.
When I say IT, I'm referring
to AIT and CIT together.
That's my usage of the
word IT for the aficionados
in the room.
And that's about 10 million
output neurons in IT
just to fix numbers.
In V1 here, you have like
37 million output neurons.
There's about 200 million
neurons in V1, similar in V2.
And many of you probably
heard about other parts
of the visual system.
Here's MT, many of you
probably heard about MT.
So you can see it's tiny
compared to some of these areas
that I'm talking about here.
I'm going to show
you some neural dam--
I'm just going to
give you a brief tour
of these different areas, so
brief, it's almost cartoonish.
But at least those of
you who haven't seen this
should at least be exposed.
So in the retina--
you guys know in
the retina there's
a bunch of cell
layers in the retina.
The retina is a
complicated device.
I think of it as a
beautiful camera.
So you're down in the retina.
To me, the key
thing in the retina
is in the end you've got some
cells that are going to project
back along the optic nerve.
So these are the
retinal ganglion cells,
they actually live
on the surface.
The light comes through,
photo receptors are here,
there is processing in
these intermediate layers,
and then there's a bunch of
retinal ganglion cell types.
There's thought to be
about 20 types or so.
The original
physiology, there are
two functional central
types where they
have on center or off center.
Let's take an on center
cell, you shine light
in the middle of
a spot-- now this
is a tiny little
spot on the retina,
the size depends on where
you are in the visual field.
But you shine a little bit
of light in the center,
the response goes up.
See the spike rate
going up here.
Put light in the surround,
the response rate goes down.
So it has an on center,
off surround profile.
And then there's
a flip type here.
So that's the basic
functional type.
When you think
about the retina, it
is tiled with all of
these point detectors that
have some nice center
surround effects.
There's some nice gain control
for overall illumination
conditions.
But my toy model
of the retina, it's
basically a really nice
pixel map coming back down
the optic track to the LGN.
OK, I'm going to skip the
LGN and go straight to V1.
People have known for a
long time, functionally V1
cells they have sensitivity
to especially edges.
They have what's called
orientation selectivity.
Hopefully this isn't
new to you guys.
Here's a simple cell in V1.
If you shine a bar
of a light on it
inside it's receptive field--
does everyone know what
a receptive field is?
I don't want to go--
OK.
It's OK if you
ask, because I want
to make sure you guys are OK.
So the receptive field, you
shine a bar light in it,
turn it on in the
right orientation,
gives good response
out of the cell.
Move it off this position,
now not much response,
there's a little bit of
an off response here.
Change the orientation,
nothing happens.
Full field illumination,
OK, so this is
called selectivity.
That is, there's some
portion of the image space
that it cares about.
It doesn't just
respond to any light
at that spot like the pixel
wise, retinal ganglion cell
would.
So now there's this
complex cell that's
also in V1, which
maintains this orientation
selectivity across a
change in position,
as shown here, also across
some changes in scale.
So it maintains it, meaning
that you have this tolerance--
so that's called position
tolerance, for position.
You can move the bar around it,
still likes that oriented bar.
But you change its
angle and it goes down,
so it still maintains
the same selectivity here
but it has some tolerance.
So you get this build up of
some orientation sensitivity
followed by some tolerance.
And there are models
from Hubel and Wiesel
that they thought that
you could build this first
and then you build
these out of these,
that's the simple version.
And here they are.
These are the Hubel
and Wiesel models,
how you build these and like
operators to build selectivity
from pixel-wise cells with
an and like operator lining
these up correctly.
You can imagine oriented
tuned cells built this way.
There's evidence for
this in physiology
that this is how
these are constructed.
The tolerance of
these complex cells
is thought to build by a
combination of simple cells.
And there's some
evidence for this.
And this is again, all the
way from Hubel and Wiesel,
who won a Nobel Prize for this
and related work in the 1960s.
And then there were a bunch
of computational models
that are really
inspired by this and I
think are still the core
models of how the system works.
And some of the original
ones that were written down
are Fukushima in
the '80s, and then
Tommy Poggio and others built
what's called an HMAX Model,
you guys have
probably heard about,
that's off of these
similar ideas, much more
refined and much more
matched to the neural data.
But I'm just try to
point out that these kind
of physiological
observations are
what inspired this class of
largely feedforward models
that you heard about much today.
So that's a brief tour of V1.
Now, what's going on in V2?
For a long time,
people thought it
was hard to tell the
difference from V1 and V2.
And I just thought
I'd show you guys,
this is a slide I stuck
in, this is from Eero
Simoncelli and Tony Movshon.
And I think you guys have Eero
teaching in the course a bit
later, so he may
say some of this.
But V2 cells have some
sensitivity to natural image
statistics that V1 cells don't.
And maybe I'll see if I
can take you through this.
So the way that they did
this is you can simulate--
so this is all driven off of
work that Eero and Tony have
done--
especially Eero has done
on texture synthesis.
So you have these
original images,
and if you run them through a
bunch of V1-like filter banks,
and then you take a new
image, a random seed, which
is like white noise,
and you try to make sure
that it would
activate populations
of V1 cells in a
similar way, there's
a large set of images that would
do that because you're just
doing summary
statistics, but these
are some examples of them.
For this image, this is one
that one might look like.
So you can see, to you, it
doesn't look the same as this.
But to V1, these are
metamers, they're
very similar in the
summary statistics in V1.
And then you start taking cross
products of these V1 summary
statistics and then
you try to match those.
And what's interesting
is you start
to get something that looks,
texture wise, much more
like this original image.
And this is a big part of
what Eero and others did
in that work.
And the reason I'm
showing you this
is that Tony's lab has gone
and recorded in V1 and V2
with these kinds of stimuli, and
the main observation they have
is that V1 doesn't care whether
you show it this or this.
To V1, these are
both the same, which
says we have the
summary statistics
for V1 right in terms of
the average V1 response.
That's all I'm showing you here.
The paper, if you want
it, is much more detailed.
But you go to V2 and
there's a big difference
between this, which V2 cells
respond to more, and this,
which they respond to less.
And really one inference
you can take from this
is that V2 neurons apply a
repeated-- another and like
operator on V1.
That's a simple inference
that these kinds of data seem
to support .
And they also tell you that
these and-like operators,
these conjunctions
of V1 statistics
tend to be in the
direction of the statistics
of the natural world, that's
naturalistic statistics.
Now lots of controls
haven't been done here
to narrow in exactly
what kinds ands,
but that's the spirit
of where the field is
in trying to understand V2.
Everybody thinks
it has something
to do with corners or a
more complicated structure.
But this is a way that
current in the field
to try to move these image
computing models forward
in V1 and V2.
And Tony likes to point out that
this is one of the strongest
differences that you
see between V1 and V2,
other than the
receptive field sizes.
So I think that's quite
some exciting work if you
don't know about it on V2.
OK, then you get up into V4
and things get much murkier.
So what's going on in V4?
Well, let me just briefly say
that one of my post-docs-- this
is more recent work just because
it builds on that earlier work.
This is Nicole Rust, when she
was a post-doc in the lab,
compared V4.
She actually compared it to IT.
I'll skip that.
But she was using these
Simoncelli scrambled images.
These are actually the
texture images from--
these are the original
images and these
are the texture versions.
So this should look like a
textured version of that.
You can see that these
algorithms don't actually
capture the object
content of these images.
And what Nicole actually
showed is that similar to what
you just saw there, in
the earlier work like V1,
V4 doesn't care about the
differences between these.
It responds similarly, as a
population, to this and this,
and this and this,
and this and this.
But IT cares a lot
about this versus this.
So this is just repeating the
same theme, the general idea
that you have and -like
operators that we think
are aligned along the
ventral stream that
are tuned to the
kind of statistics
that you tend to
encounter in the world.
And this is some of the
evidence for it in V2,
and then later in V4, and
IT, and Nicole's work,
if you piece that all together.
When you go to a place
like V4, remember V4
is now like three levels up.
And what does V4 do?
Look, this is
Jack's work in 1996.
This is from Jack
Gallant when he was
working with David Van Essen.
And people had some
ideas that maybe there
are these certain functions
that V4 neurons like,
and they would show these--
the same thing people
have done in V2,
they would show a bunch
of images like this
and figure out, well, does it
like these Cartesian gratings
or these curved ones.
And you know what, you
get out of this is,
you could tell some
story about it,
but you get a bunch of
responses out of it.
The color indicates
the response.
And you kind of look at it, and
people would tell some stories,
but it really was just
kind of like tea leaves.
Here's a bunch of
data, we don't really
know what these V4
neurons were doing.
This was a science paper, so
you could go back and read it.
And then Ed Connor
and Anitha Pasupathy
worked together a
few years after that
to try to figure out more
about what V4 neurons do.
And they did things
like take images
like this, which were
isolated, and try
to cut them into parts, like
curved parts, pointy parts,
curved, concave, convex.
And this was motivated off of
some psychology literature.
And they would
define these based
on the center of the object.
So this wasn't an
image computable model,
it was just a
basis set that they
built around these
silhouette objects.
And so they made this basis set
about any kind of silhouetted
object they like here.
They hypothesized
that they could
fit the responses of V4
neurons in this basis set.
And this was their
attempt to do it.
They could actually
fit quite well.
And that's kind of
what's being shown here.
Here's the response
of a V4 neuron.
The color indicates the
depth of the response.
You can see, this is sort
of like that previous slide,
you're looking at tea leaves.
It looks complicated,
but under this model
they were able to, in the
shape space, explain about half
of the response
variants of V4 neurons.
The upshot is, that V4 curve
is about some combination
of curves.
And then later, Scott
Brincat, with Ed,
went on into posterior
IT and showed
that maybe some combinations
of these V4 cells
could fit posterior IT
responses quite well.
So if you read the
literature in V4 and IT,
you'll come across
these studies.
And they are important
ones to look at.
Unfortunately,
they don't give you
an image computable model of
what these neurons are doing.
But it's some of the work
that you should know about
if you want to look
in V4 or early IT,
so I'm telling it to you.
So let me go on to IT,
which is what I want to talk
about for the rest of today.
Again, I'm talking
about AIT and CIT.
And I'll just quickly say
that the anatomy, again,
suggests that the IT is
the central 10 degrees.
And even though V1, V2, and V4
cover the whole visual field,
if you make injections
in V4, that's
shown here, where
you make injections
in the more peripheral parts
of the V4 representation, which
is up here, that you don't get
much projection into IT, which
is here.
You don't see much green color,
whereas, you make projections
in the center part of
V4, these red sites here,
you see much more coverage
into IT, which is shown here.
So when I say 10
degrees, that's rough.
Everything in biology is messy.
But this is some of the
evidence, beyond recordings,
there's anatomical evidence
that as you go down into IT,
you are more and more focused
on the central 10 degrees.
OK, let me talk about a little
bit of the history of IT
recordings.
This is when people got
excited about IT, in the 70s.
This is work by Charlie Gross,
who's one of the first people
to record an IT cortex.
And I'll show you
what they did here.
This was in an era where,
remember, Hubel and Wiesel
had just done their
work in the '60s.
And they recorded from
the cat visual cortex.
And they had found
these edge cells,
and they ended up winning
the Nobel Prize for that.
So it was the heyday
of like, let's record
and figure out what
makes cells go.
So they were brave enough to put
an electrode down an IT cortex
in 1970 and said, what
makes this neuron go.
Remember, that's an
encoding question,
what's the image content
that will drive this neuron.
And it's fun to just
look back on this
and what they were doing.
So they didn't have
computer monitors.
They were actually
waving around stimuli
in front of the animals.
This is an anesthetized
animal on a table.
This is a monkey.
Actually, they
started with a cat
and then they later
went to monkey.
The use of these stimuli
was begun one day when,
having failed to drive a unit
with any light stimulus-- that
probably means spots
of light, edges things
that Hubel and Wiesel
had been using.
We waved a hand at
the stimulus screen,
they waved in front
of the monkey,
and elicited a very
vigorous response
from the previously
unresponsive neuron.
And then we spent the next
12 hours-- so the animal's
anesthetized on the table, their
recording from this neuron.
It's 12 hours because
nothing's moving,
so you can record for
a long period of time.
So singular neuron,
they're recording,
listening to the spikes.
We spent the next 12 hours
testing various paper cut
outs in attempt to find
the trigger feature.
You can see, that's a
Hubel and Wiesel idea,
what makes this neuron go.
What's the best
thing, that's become
a lot of what the
field spent time doing.
Trigger feature for this unit,
when the entire stimulus set
were used, were ranked according
to the strength of the response
that they produced.
We could not find a
simple physical dimension
that correlated with
this rank order.
However, the rank order
of adequate stimuli
did correlate with
similarity for us,
that means
psychophysical judged,
to the shadow of a monkey hand.
So these are their rank
order of the stimuli.
And they say look, it looks like
it's some sort of hand neuron.
That's all I know
how to describe it.
I can't find some
simple thing on here.
So this kind of study then
launched a whole domain
where people started to go
in to record these neurons
and they found interesting
different types.
Bob Desimone, who worked
with Charlie Gross,
later showed much more
nicely under more controlled
conditions, yes, there are
indeed neurons that respond.
You can see more to these hand--
this is the post stimulus time
histogram, lots of spikes, lots
of spikes, lots of spikes--
respond more to these hands
than to these other kind
of stimuli here.
So you could say,
these neurons have
tuned to specific combinations
of high selectivity.
You'll hear from
Winrich that others
had shown that you
could record some
of the neurons are really like
faces that you could find,
and not so much hands.
So you could find
neurons that seem
to have some interesting
selectivity in IT cortex.
And then others
later went on to show
in a number of studies-- this
is from Nico Logothetis' work
of a number of years later.
It's just one example that this
selectivity had some tolerance
to, say, the position
of the stimulus, that's
what's shown here.
The fact that these
bars are high just
means that it tolerates
movement in where the--
sorry, this is size,
degrees of visual angle.
This is position, moving
the stimulus around.
So this was known
for a number of years
that there's some tolerance
to position and size
changes at least.
OK, so I'm putting
these up and you say,
there's some selectivity
and there's some tolerance.
And that should remind you of
what we already said in V1,
there's some selectivity,
simple cells.
There's some tolerance,
complex cells.
So you have the
same themes here,
just different kinds of
types of stimuli being used.
Then people really went on, in
the 80s especially, and said,
let's go after this
trigger feature.
And Tanaka's group really
went after this really hard.
Tanaka's group would
find the best stimulus
they would find, dangle
a bunch of objects
in front of a recorded
neuron, find the best out
of a whole set of
objects, and then they
try to do a reduction.
They'd try to figure out,
how can I reduce this.
This is their attempt to reduce
the stimulus to its features
without lowering
the neural response.
So high response, high response,
high response, high response,
high response, suddenly I
do this, the response drops.
I do this, the response drops.
And they have lots
of examples of this.
And they want you to try to
get to the simplest thing that
could capture the response.
And when they did this, they
would take stimuli like this,
and end up with stimuli
that looked like that.
Now, many of you should
probably start to wonder here,
there's lots of paths
for stimulus space.
It's not clear that these
are elemental in any way.
There's lots of ways that
you can show with modeling
that you can get easily lost in
this space of navigating around
here.
This is just, again,
a history of the work.
This is the kind of things
that people were doing.
And then from that,
they presented
what we think of as the
ice cube model of IT,
that I think is actually still
a very reasonable approximation.
They not only
showed that neurons
tended to like certain
relatively reduced stimulus
features, not full
objects, but that they
are gathered together.
So these are millimeter
scale regions of IT
that nearby neurons,
within a millimeter or so,
have similar preferences.
They're not just
scattered willy-nilly
throughout the tissue.
When you go record nearby
neurons, they're similar.
So there's some mapping
within IT cortex.
This is schematic here.
This is optical imaging
data of IT cortex also
from Tanaka's
group that show you
that these different
blobs of tissue
get activated by different
images shown here.
And I'm just showing
you the scale of this,
it's around a little
less than a millimeter.
And our lab has
evidence of this too.
So there's some sort of
spatial organization in IT,
but we really don't really
yet understand the features,
these elemental features yet,
or at least, not at this time.
Then later, there's lots
of beautiful work in IT.
Again, I'm probably not
telling you all of it.
Some of the most
exciting work recently--
and you'll hear about
this from Winrich,
that people started
to use fMRIs.
So Doris Tsao and Winrich
Freiwald and Marge Livingstone
all together started to
use fMRI data to compare
faces versus objects.
This was motivated
from human work,
by work like Nancy
Kanwisher lab and others.
What they found was
that in monkeys,
you could find different
parts that would show up,
what are called
face patches, where
you have a relative preference
for faces over objects.
Again, I don't want to take
all of Winrich's talk here,
but you have these
different patches here.
And then what's really cool
is, you go in and record
from these patches and then you
find a very enriched locations
for face neurons.
And these enriched
locations were known
from a number of other studies.
But this is a nice correlation
between functional imaging
and this enrichment
of these face cells.
And that's what's shown here,
that these neurons respond
mostly to faces and not
so much other objects.
Although, you see they still
sort of respond to these.
So this kind of says
fMRI and physiology are
telling you similar things.
It also tells you there's some
spatial clumping, at least
for face-like objects, at a
scale of a few millimeters
or so, the size
of these patches.
OK, so that's larger
scale organization.
This is data from our own lab
that shows the same thing.
Maybe I'll just skip through
this in the interest of time--
that we can map and record
the neurons very precisely,
map them spatially and
compare that with fMRI.
So this is just a larger field
of view maps of the same idea.
So what we have
then, just to wrap up
this whirlwind tour
of the ventral stream,
is that we had some untangled
explicit information.
And what I want to try to
convince you of now, is that--
I've told you about
the ventral stream,
but I'm going to try to
tell you that, in IT cortex,
this is a powerful
representation for encoding
object information.
And then we'll take a break
because we've already probably
been going a while.
Yeah, about 10 more minutes
and then we'll take a break.
So what I've told you is, I've
led you up the ventral stream,
I've given you a
bit of the history,
so now let's talk about
IT more precisely.
So now this is work
from my own lab.
You go in and record IT.
You go record extracellularly.
You travel down into IT
cortex, which is down here.
And you record from this.
And similar to what you
saw, another version of what
you saw from Charlie
Gross or Bob Desimone,
you show a bunch of images.
And they could be
arbitrary images.
You take an IT recording site,
and see these little dots,
those are action potential
spikes out of a particular IT
site.
And these are repeatable.
You have some Poisson
variability here.
But you see that there's
more spikes here,
there's little more here,
less here, less there.
These images are all
randomly interleaved
when you collect the data,
as I'll show you in a minute.
And you go to different sites
and it likes different images.
So there is certainly
some image selectivity.
This should not be surprising
because I already showed
you this from previous work.
This is just data
from our own lab.
You can also see now that
you are looking closely
at the time lag, remember, I
said around 100 milliseconds
stimulus on.
Stimulus off, the
stimulus is actually off
before the spikes actually
start to occur out
here in IT because,
again, there's a long time
lag, 100 milliseconds.
OK, so that's what the
neural responses look like.
I don't know if you
guys can hear this,
maybe I should have
hooked up audio.
Maybe you might
be able to hear--
this is actually a
recording that Chou Hung did
when he collected his data in
my lab for the early studies
we did in the lab.
I don't know if
you guys can hear.
[STATIC]
[BEEP]
Those high beeps are the
animal getting reward
for fixating on that dot.
You're not even going to
be able to parse that.
I mean, you hear the
spikes clicking by, those--
[STATIC]
Those are action potentials.
And I don't expect you to look
at anything like, oh, it's
a face neuron, or whatever.
I just want you to get a
feel for how those data were
originally collected.
This is a pretty grainy video.
But you get the idea.
You collect data like that.
And again, you can find
selectivity in those population
patterns, as I just showed you.
But then, Gabriel and Tommy
and I, so the three of us,
I think all in this
room, way back when
in 2005 said, well look,
the population of IT
might have good,
useful information
for solving this
difficult object manifold
tangling problem.
It might be a good
explicit representation.
So we did a, what I call,
early test of this idea.
We took this simple image set
from eight different categories
that we had chosen.
And there's good stories of
why we chose those objects,
if you like to hear them.
But let me just say, simple
objects, we moved them
across position and scale,
and we collected the responses
of IT of a bunch
of sites to changes
to all these different
visual images.
And we showed them
as I just showed you.
We just showed them
for 100 milliseconds.
This is this core
recognition regime,
were just showing them
for 100 milliseconds.
And then we show another
one, and they're just
randomly interleaved.
And from this,
what you do is you
could get a
population set of data
where we recorded 350 IT sites.
Here's a sample of 63 sites.
This is 78 images, the
mean neural response
here is the mean
response to an image.
This is 78 of the
images we showed.
There's nothing for you to read
into here to say, other than,
you have this rich
population data.
And now our question is, well,
what lives in this population
data that we've collected.
Is it explicit with
regard to categories?
So we come back to
what I showed you
earlier about those
tangled manifolds and said,
we need simple decoding tools.
Can a simple decoding tool
look at that population
and tell me what's out there?
And again, we were using
linear classifiers at the time,
because we took
that, as you heard
from Haim as our operational
definition of what
a simple tool is.
And if it could decode
information about the object
identity, then we'd
say, well, that means,
by that operational
definition, this
is explicit, available,
accessible information, or just
generally good.
So if you imagine that the
activity-- this is schematic.
Each dot, this is
neuron one, neuron two,
and you could have a
bunch of IT neurons.
But if you can
separate any object
from all the other
object, these points
represent the
population response
to each image of an object.
Remember, there's many
images of each object.
But if you could
linearly separate that,
that would mean it was explicit.
And if you had a hard
time separating it,
this would be implicit.
These are like tangled
object manifold.
This is Inaccessible,
or bad, information.
So we just-- we,
and when I mean we,
I mean Chou Hung,
who led the study.
Gabriel, Tommy, and I did this.
We took the response of
an image, like this one.
It produced a population vector.
Again, we recorded
a bunch of neurons.
We recorded them sequentially
and then pieced together
this population vector.
So these are the
spikes simulated off
a population of IT.
We could do various things.
In fact, I think Gabriel
did everything possible,
as I remember at the time.
And one of the things we
did was just count spikes.
One of the simple things, that
turns out to work quite well,
is count the spikes
over 100 milliseconds.
So this neuron counts spikes.
That gives you a
number, one number here,
count spikes get one number.
So you have n neurons,
you get n numbers.
So it's a point in a n
dimensional state space where
n is the number of neurons.
And then we had already
pre-divided the images
into different
categories, as shown here.
These are the categories.
And again, we just
asked how well
you could do faces
versus non-faces,
toys versus non-toys,
so on and so forth.
These are old slides.
But you get the idea,
is that basically, you
don't need that many
sites to already get
to very high levels
of performance
on both categorization
and identification.
The interesting
thing about this was
that you could
solve simple forms
of this invariance problem
in this representation
quite easily.
That if you just trained on
the central objects, the center
and size, the simple three
degree size center position,
and test it on the
same thing, just
held out repeats of this
data, you did quite well.
That's a baseline.
But what's interesting is you
test at different position
and scale.
And then you also do
almost nearly as well.
So you naturally generalize
to these other conditions
by training on these
simple conditions.
So this is evidence
that the population
is a good basis set for
solving these kind of problems.
A few number of training
examples on this population
then generalizes,
well, across conditions
makes the problem hard.
So again, we published
that a long time ago.
This was an early
step to say, look,
the phenomenology looks
right for the story that I've
been telling you so far.
You can't do this easily in
earlier visual areas like V1,
or simulated V1 or V4.
And we later show
that a number of ways.
This is consistent with
work I was showing you
with Logothetis
position tolerance, size
tolerance, the selectivity.
It's really just an explicit
test of the idea population
encoding.
So the take home here is that
there's this explicit object
representation in IT.
I didn't prove to
you that this is
the link, this predictive
model to decoding yet.
We're going to talk
about that next.
But this was some of
the important population
phenomenology that we did.
What I try to tell you today--
hopefully I've introduced you
to the problem of visual object
recognition and the
way we restricted it
to core object recognition.
We talked a lot about predictive
models as being the goal,
although I haven't
presented much to you yet.
Hopefully, that's the
second part of the talk.
I've given you a tour
of the ventral stream.
But it was a poor tour.
I'm sure everybody
i work with would
say that you've neglected
all this work because there's
no way I can do that all
in even a whole week.
I just tried to hit some
of the highlights for you.
And I told you that
the IT population
seems to have solved
a key problem,
this sort of invariance
problem that I set up.
And one way to step back and
say, over the last 40 years
or so, from those early
studies of Charlie Gross
or even Hubel and Wiesel, we,
the field of ventral stream
physiology, we've largely
described important
phenomenology.
Even that last study is
population phenomenology.
And so now we need these
more advanced models.
So the next phase of the field
is developing and testing
these predictive
models that I've
motivated at the
beginning, but I
haven't given you much of yet.
So this was hopefully a bit
of history and set context
to where we are.